[Musique]
en direct du canada sur la côte est
canadienne à montréal c'est l'émission
tam-tam canada de russie fusée à travers
le monde entier ces pratiques le web
c'est fou ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui avec le web et bien sûr nous
on était là au début du web donc ça fait
longtemps qu'on est diffuseur le monde
aujourd'hui on est un peu de compétition
alors c'est pour ça qu'on l'a 7 mai
l'émission qu'on appelle tomtom canada
qui vous parvient en direct tous les
vendredis en compagnie de nos collègues
aujourd'hui mangue banane et joyeuse à
lui donnais mon ami alors il y as
chantin l'alléchante alkyde avec de bons
joua les sanctions stéphane regarder le
cadeau que le père noël nous apparaît
oui bah ça c'est gentil on vous sait ça
fait six mois qu'ils ont trop longtemps
ismaël est trop talentueux et dès que
dieu on a besoin de quelqu'un quelque
part on va chercher c'est la vérité
merci merci j'apprécie on va vérifier
que la grosse bulle fonctionner encore
après cette pause de noël qui aura duré
trois semaines à l'émission vous avez
deux boutons vous peser sur les 200 ha
c'est moi qui fais s'attaquer à une
première cette semaine de parler
davantage que moi je sais que c'est pas
facile mais ayant la canardière jeu le
moins je parle de moi je risque de vous
communiquer bon d'accord
une crypte canadienne ouais c'est de
nouveau c'est un début oui parce que
j'ai la grippe norvégienne elle est
cruelle sibérienne mais la grippe
espagnole
oui mais l auteur n'a marqué aucun point
ça rappelle des 12
oui c'est ça mais la personne qui est
vivant aujourd'hui qui se souvient je
pense à moins de la seule qui est le cas
à 117 à 118 ans la japonaise c'est vrai
son anniversaire cette semaine
2 c'est à travers voilà écoutez comment
ça fonctionne cette émission il ya le
jeu de la grosse brouille 3 e par
émission sans boule à perdre par
émission qui actions vont l'être dans le
groupe 2 istanbul autour de nous pour
des trois jeux et puis bon vous allez
voir ça fonctionne et le sujet des
missions c'est quoi le sujet de
l'émission c'est de la crise entre les
etats-unis et l'iran et ça pousse aurait
pu être sa soeur était un bon choix
éditorial
mais non malheureusement non mais vous
allez voir peut-être un jour de ma vie
non ça on va en parler certainement j'en
suis sûr c'est inévitable mais j'ai
pensé lancer les milliers de l'année sur
une note positive
ouais c'est ça qu'on a besoin de tous de
prendre l'aspiration ce qu'est ce que
c'est
vidéo cinq à huy où il va nous aider
tout le monde va jouer avec vous vous
regardez cinq images elles vont pas
assez vite tout un tas de mesures c'est
quoi le sujet aujourd'hui alors d'un
petit bassin ont bâti une image à une
autre on laisse passer à d'accord le g7
reste comme c'est de la télévision et de
la radio vous parlez a donc c'est nos
données personnelles ça on en a parlé
comme ça à faire avec quelque chose
comprendre personnel oui et leur mère
comme un c lectronique absolument être
vit sa petite soeur
le vendredi noir les amériques colis et
l'envoi de colis wee aa mais gaspillage
cela dit voilà sujets comme ça pour
lancer l'année l'année aurait pu être
l'année de l'environnement regardez ce
monsieur là qui est qui trône ça c'est
un magasin ou en revint tous les
articles qui ont été retourné qui ont
été retournés mais la plupart d'entre
eux dit on je sais pas quel est le
pourcentage se retrouve ben porte la
plupart mais je sais pas quel
pourcentage ont reposé la question un
spécialiste aujourd'hui dans quelques
instants
il ya une bonne partie qui se retrouvent
au dépotoir plutôt que d'examiner ce que
le client retourne ça prend trop de
temps ça coûte cher on envoie sonne
alors est-ce que vous avez retourné des
articles non non non non non mon
fournisseur de palets retournons au quai
s'assure de choisir la bonne affaire moi
j'ai retourné de l'équipement
électronique
1 pour quelles raisons ah bah écoutez ça
nous amène à la première question
aujourd'hui la question de la grosse
boule 20 boules à perdre aussi on
affiche de la question pour le plaisir
de tous et chacun
quelle est la raison principale pour
laquelle les consommateurs retourne
produit c'était les raisons que j'ai
évoquées moi-même auprès d'une compagnie
cet incendie est ce que c'est un milieu
défaut avec cet objet est ce que c b il
ya une panne concernant ça fonctionne
pas bien
est ce que c'est c'est hors jeu changer
d'idée ou est-ce que céder aucune de ces
réponses
j'irai peut-être avec la réponse b comme
une panne
j'irai avec la change d'idée vous avez
changé d'idée ouais mais vous a changé
d'idée on voulait pas ce cadeau mais on
voulait un autre nom je garde mon idée
est de changer d'idée vous voilez sous
moi je garde
enfin la réponse b une vanne lever la
main si vous perdez 20 points ou la
fiche de la bonne réponse pour d autres
mondes changé
c'est plus facile en général on reçoit
des cadeaux neufs donc a pas de raison
qu'ils tombent en panne ou qui à défaut
de fabrication
voilà c'est tirés d'un sondage qui a été
effectué en grande bretagne mais c'est
ça s'applique sur l'ensemble de
l'amérique du nord grande-bretagne à
particules ils ont posé la question est
ce que le téléphone vous avez retourné
là est ce qu'ils font il ya un problème
non 63% des téléphones retourner à chez
sony était ya aucun problème et c'est le
client qui a changé d'idée qc du
j'arrive pas faire fonctionner soit donc
je m'en débarrasse
où est ce que ça se retrouve le
téléphone c'est la question oui on va
justement téléphone on va trouver les
réponses
voici notre spécialiste aujourd'hui marc
tassé professeur à l'école de gestion
telfer c'est à ottawa dans la région
d'ottawa professeur bonjour bonjour à
vous tous alors bien sûr on a beaucoup
de questions pour vous mais d'abord
comment êtes-vous un spécialiste du
retour des articles achetés en magasin
ben moi je fais rendre compte qu'il y
avait tellement de l'afrique était
retournée donc on est désolé d'avoir des
études plus approfondies pour voir les
comportements des consommateurs et les
raisons pour lesquelles leur effet une
étude de quitter basée sur d'autres
études ce qui ça que je viens on ne va
pas vous faire en pente reprise qui
comme avant pour voir comme tels quels
étaient les pourcentages de marchandises
ikea veut tourner et qui était le
pourcentage de ma famille qui était tout
simplement détruits est-ce que c'était
une enquête qui portait une analyse dans
kate qui portait sur la situation
l'amérique du nord ou au canada ou au
québec seulement ou même à montréal et
c'est quoi les plus grands constats de
cette recherche l'a offert entre conques
aveyron 8 pour fins de tous les temps à
aligner retourner et plus spécifiquement
le domaine du vêtement fait car un
parfum qui est retourné équipe
simplement détruits et c'est quoi les
raisons qui sont invoquées par les
clients les clients ce qu'ils vont dire
comme tel on a fait trois camps
différents on n'était pas certain qu
est-ce qui ne dépend de nous faire donc
on trois couleurs différentes pourront
de ce fait un bel accueil on retourne ma
veste
c'est incroyable parce qu'il ya combien
de pourcentage qui est détruit de ses
habits
car un parfum pourquoi sont-ils détruit
la réforme très bien fait pour faire en
sorte que ça coûterait trop cher de les
retourner aux fabricants donc le fait de
les remballer les retourner et par la
suite établi qu'en faisaient que les
nestois de nouveau et qu'il irait art
balle donc facile de tout simplement les
envoyer au sud dans tout cela il ya un
reportage j'ai vu ça ce matin et j'ai
trouvé que la coïncidence était
intéressante mais malheureuse de la fois
à toronto il ya une dame cliente qui se
promenait comme ça à l'arrière d'un
centre d'achats et qu' à l'arrière d'une
boutique de vêtements pour enfants et
qui a retrouvé un container rempli de
vêtements qui avait été découpée de
mitaines de gilets tout découpé on a
dépassé les six ont à travers et on
avait jeté sa la compagnie se défend en
disant qu allen politique de de
réutilisation du matériel mais là vous
dire en regardant ce qui c'est passé
dans le cas précis de cette succursale
je ne nommerai pas la compagnie pourquoi
déranger personne
mais écoutez est-ce que couper les
articles y détruire ça fait aussi partie
du jeu qu'à le faire
au canada on ne régule créé un fort que
je suis entreprises démontrent un leurre
souple et venta mais plutôt un automate
ou pays ont écrit fiscales donc fait
pour 76 dans la salle de marché n'est
offert qu'en qui avaient des gains
qu'ils avaient été coupés à des endroits
stratégiques pour faire un fort plus il
n'est plus vraiment pu être là quand
vous parlez de gain fiscal ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça c'est de l'action
syndicale qui peuvent agir sur ce
n'était pas de mettre le taux
d'imposition marginal et est ce qu'à un
moment donné durant l'étude vous formulé
quelques recommandations pour une
réutilisation de ces vêtements parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya des centres
communautaires qui en ont grandement
besoin
nous ce qu'on recommence fait que les
gones à la charge la loi et dans les
vingt sept se pose entreprise pour
pouvoir les donner dans des marchés
secondaires que ça ferait niveau du
bénévolat
que ce soit les règlements au niveau
d'entreprises qui vont dire avant la
livre i réduit la problèmatique fait que
la plupart des fabricants ne veulent pas
comme tels qu'ils viennent
leurs biens circulation des fluides
inférieurs ce qui existe toujours
demander mieux les jeter pour maintenir
l'offre et la demande donc c'est
vraiment une approche très
macroéconomique et nous ce qu'on demande
exemple aux pense qu'en france ainsi
qu'en allemagne
les romains ont développé des lois qui
exige aux entreprises de démontrer
qu'ils ont tous faire leur possible pour
de trouver un marché secondaire
ses vêtements avant de les détruire la
professeure on passe des images d'une
chapelle récent une palette de
d'équipements électroniques qui ont été
retournés et qui ont été rachetés par
des citoyens souris b il paraissait une
pratique qui a des gens qui disaient
quand même des sous à faire dans cette
mine de déchets ce que vous avez discuté
nous parler de ces tendances est en
avance qu'ils vont passer pour retourner
votre fric électronique qui vont prendre
un bois de deux qui partent de pied on
l'a remplie d'afrique électroniques vont
la veuve en 200 dollars mais vous gagnez
plus que vous avez une valeur d'environ
550 dollars dont pour les jeunes ça peut
donner le plus c'est un genre de marché
secondaire
donc ils font fait qu'il ne l'ait rien
balle peut il est vrai une telle qu'elle
l'aimait pas une blague remplir la boîte
la remettre en vie vous savez que vous
avez une valeur minimale de franck fife
un cap et vous payer 200 dollars peau
c'est intéressant parce que aussi de
consommateurs et pas toujours au courant
moi je suis pas au courant que si je
rentre je ramène un habit
systématiquement détruits est-ce qu'il
ya aussi une volonté de pouvoir
permettre aux gens d'être au courant de
ces pratiques là oui effectivement à de
plus en plus les entreprises vont
expliquer comme tf109 entreprises que ce
contrat et on dira j'ai regardé nous ce
qu'on fait quand vous de les retourner
on les a vus d'un de nos entrepôts et on
les revend à rades et donc on informe le
consommateur
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les retours
ben on imagine qui a comme une empreinte
écologique heureux dit à ce processus de
destruction des vêtements qui sont
retournés est-ce que cela ne vient pas
en quelque sorte remettre en question la
pertinence du commerce électronique
totalement animaux on peut a fait
plusieurs choses
il est retourné alors que son grand
magasin qu'on achète 3 par deux
pantalons et qu'on a on retourne deux
lendemain
au tfc entièrement alors que sous
couvert d'anonymat on se permet de faire
peut-être de prendre des fusions un peu
moins les tricks que si on avait être la
personne et ses convictions entre a
laissé moi pour vous poser des questions
parce que vous nous apprenez des choses
la vie véritablement là mais moi je
connaissais un peu le sujet mais si on
tombe dans un état trop de détails
parlons des différences internationale
on a parlé de dégrèvement fiscal ou d'un
crédit d'impôt pour les entreprises
canadiennes
on veut changer la loi vous disiez
comment ça se passe quelles sont les
grandes différences je sais pas
continental ici y en a mais ont décidé
plutôt d'accorder un crédit
fillon dément condé aurait donc exemple
vous avez un lien qu'il a avec les 100
dollars la fecofa 200 dollars on vous le
retour vous le revendez à 40 dollars
mais le gouvernement a obtenu crayon de
20 dans l'ordre donc si la fsu une femme
additionnel nos impôts pour compenser
fait que parce qu'il était endommagé
vous avez dû le voir un prix inférieur
on vous donne un statut ordonné à leurs
ventes alors que kannad aux dangers sont
bien les quatre sites à le détruire
[Rires]
malheureusement oui
nous pensons qu'il serait peut-être
temps que les dirigeants du monde c'est
un peu idéaliste comme jd ben que ces
dirigeants là se mettre ensemble autour
d'une table pour repenser un e-commerce
et ré définir un peu le contour de ce
type de commerce là pour éviter le genre
de gaspillage auquel nous assistons
aujourd'hui effectivement et je crois
qu'elle est plus grands consommateurs
d'achat en ligne se sont nés les gens
que faure le fumant jeunes donc est ce
qu'il ya comme avantages sont des
personnes que la coop beaucoup
d'importance ouverte et de
l'environnement à la responsabilité
faveur de l'entreprise ainsi qu'à la
bonne gouvernance dont une fois qu'ils
vont être confuse et que les choix
qu'ils font se retrouvaient du site
d'enfouissement ou d'incinération je
crois qu'il va y avoir une confiance
relation qui va être fait mais qui vont
peut-être réduit aux besoins leur
empreinte écologique
évidemment en excluant ce point de vue
vous venait d'insulter les plus vieux
camp consommateurs
depuis ce qu'on a une dernière question
est ce que vous sentez une écoute de la
part des institutions pour permettre ces
avantages fiscaux que vous parliez
tantôt est-ce que vous vous sentez qu'il
ya une écoute quand même vous avec
l'écouté plus ou moins là parce qu'en ce
moment les règles les avantages donc
lompo vraiment tendance à écouter trop
mais je fais que certains politiciens
vont en faire un cheval de bataille et
pour eux c'est quelque chose qui traite
le mans inacceptable et je parle qu'avec
les études qu'ils demandent
ça va faire le dos n'est plus comme
telle date du maire pour pouvoir
défendre point monsieur marc tassé et ce
fut un plaisir de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui à l'émission dommage que
vous ne nous nous sommes dit que vous ne
pouviez pas devoir mais vous pouvez vous
reprendre sur facebook on sera rediffusé
dans quelques instants une fois
l'émission terminée et merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé aujourd'hui je l'avais
entendu l'émission anglaise si j ai dit
à mon égard français le numéro un dans
le domaine de l'information j'écoute que
les choses en informations mais
sérieusement j'avais écouté ça et je
trouvais très articulé mais l'attaquant
plus articulée en français l'idée je
vais lancer un site web
je vais aller acheter des affaires sur
ebay je jure cette idée sinon il ya un
filon surconsommation actuellement ma
note de crédit de vente
j'ai une réputation journalistes ouais
c'est ça à ses heures perdues des bonnes
on fait quoi pour perdre déboule d'abord
on est ministre on appuie sur les
boutons en action les deux manettes on
n'est pas la radio quelque chose on
affiche à la télévision pour le plaisir
de tous notre deuxième question
aujourd'hui
voici la question sur le sondage crop au
canada quel pourcentage des
consommateurs laisse dormir à la maison
deux appareils électroniques alors
lamballe potes de ce qu'on a acheté
récemment l'a peut-être peut-être que
vous considérez que vous avez acheté la
semaine dernière et vieux ça va
tellement mais je pense que parce que je
me sens un peu coupable par rapport à sa
part avancé question alors on peut les
garder comme des archives ou un qu'elle
pensait témoin de l'histoire pour nos
descendants
pensez vous que c'est comme dans les
familles canadiens d'avoir des articles
contre s'est pas débarrassé au recyclage
correctement qui reste comme ça à la
maison
est-ce que c'est à 62% des des vieux
appareils électroniques qu'il est qu'on
laisse dormir à la maison à ce que ces
bébés 72%
est ce que c'est c'est 80 2% ou est ce
que c'est des 92 %
je vous avertis la bonne réponse termine
par deux partout c'était déjà abonnés à
10 c'est une des cartes forcément ben
ouais bon temps 92 simple ouais j'ai pas
trop 24 72 cents je suis raisonnable
c'est quand même beaucoup et j'aime ça
soit 92 j'aimerais j'aimerais pas gagné
ouais mais 92 ce serait se sont amusés
mais ce serait énorme
[Musique]
ouais j'espère me tromper cette fois on
affiche la bonne réponse avec les
astérix ça va j'ai pensé que c'était
plus élevé que je pense qu'on est
ensemble qui sera toujours ma dit que
quelques amis à une campagne
si vous suivez ce qu'on fait là la
maison vous indiquant une date à
laquelle il a des gens qui vont passer
collecter vous n'en aurez en charge et
de chansons non non mais moi je
ressources est également que je reçois
presque tous les ans avant je jette tout
ce que je reçois la maison avec ses
salles mais désormais le temps de
rédiger cette journée on la voit la
maison je sais pas de sens a désormais
j'en est essentiellement tout ce qui en
termes de volumes de ce désir la blonde
des ordinateurs je sais pas quand est-ce
que je pourrais m'en débarrasser il ya
une journée par année où je peux aller
où j'habite cgt en campagne je sais pas
alors moins évident ces campagnes il ya
de vastes espaces
vous avez occupé qu'on veut garder vert
alors je garde ça parce que je sais
qu'elles émettent il ya des métaux
précieux mais que si ça se retrouve dans
l'environnement je vais faire mal à tout
le monde surtout à moi-même donc pas ce
que ça va se retrouver dans la nappe
phréatique et moi je bois de l'eau qui
vient de mes seules voies jarny la
jeunesse et j'attends là je sais quelle
date où je veux y aller avec mon retour
mais je me repose pas au besoin à
l'engagement
j'ai fait a fait la ferrari faire un
fait enfin quelqu'un qui s'occupe de
ferraille
ok et puis je lui ai dit tu peux
apprendre ça et puis ça aussi il annonce
aux cheveux tressés voulais pas ça m'a
déçu j'ai du mal à vous l'âme en
occasion annuelle atteint d'un trouble
d'accumulation compulsif non j'ai pas de
problème psychologiquement
bon été pour en savoir plus sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui vous allez voir comment on
va bien terminer notre histoire avec
alice on a c'est notre vidéo que nuire
aux 5
j'appelle ça c'est très simple mais
c'est aujourd'hui de travail sont très
simple ça conclut un examen pourra
savoir plus facilement
voilà découvrez nos archives c'est sur
la page ouest de taling aujourd'hui
c'est pas facile à lire avec sans
lunettes là maintenant ça défile vite
c'est sur leur sillage oui
l'obsolescence on en a parlé récemment
cette mission doit fédéral son
obsolescence pour bliss et voilà puis on
va dessin tout à fait un bail à un
bateau peut racheter des bateaux oui
vous rappelle ici oui je pense que c'est
un sujet récemment il a dessus un bateau
qui polluent l'environnement et qui
traîne quelque part dans les eaux dans
l'ouest canadien quelque chose comme ça
voilà c'est ça c'est vous qui avez signé
la
oui tout à fait oui je m'en souviens en
fait c'était pato qui sont susceptibles
de contenir les matières dangereuses du
pétrole évidemment parce que c'est des
matières qui lorsqu'elles sont déversés
dans les eaux dans les océans sont très
très polluante ans pour la biodiversité
présente dans tous les espèces présentes
dans cette annonce et puis vous vous
disiez qu'on peut pas des commandes est
commissionné recycler ses navires au
canada parce qu'on n'a pas en fait
des fois on n'a pas toujours la
technologie pour le faire et il faut
comme les envoyer vers des endroits
beaucoup plus favorable à cela
donc c'est dans cet article oui c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très difficile
à faire et ça prend quand même des
connaissances techniques de façon
sécuritaire seulement ferrailleur a
refusé d'en porter le bateau et non ça
c'est un peu trop tendre à quelques
années parcours ça serait payant
sexuelle découpé avec le chalumeau la
sacoche hommage à un homme qui respecte
alors éviter que mes fins qui est des
matières dangereuses qui se retrouvent
dans l'air je sais très sérieux est ce
que vous êtes pour le plaisir le dernier
plaisir de la journée on va rappeler
vous avez perdu 5 en bout la lys et
jusque là c'est encore sûr et ça ça va
vite
j'en avais perdu 30 d'accor qui
dégringole rapidement restera cinq ans
que la gerbe ou à ne pas perdre
vous appuyez on va passer la question
ici peu plus tôt je vous parlais de d'un
coup de sonde effectué pour le compte de
l'association pour le recyclage des
produits électroniques et qu'on appelle
voici quel nom donne la oak cellulaire
tablettes et ordinateurs portables qui
traîne quelque part à la maison sous
nouvelle expression et lettres aux
ordures
parce que c'est des cycles année ça tu
as rien est-ce que c'est des fous tu
t'en des bars à soupe la c'est sert plus
à rien ouais sert plus haut sarpe une
serpillière hier lc 10 électro ordures
ou que ce pub assez bien écrit ça
quand tu t'en débarrasser est-ce que
c'est des recyclables vite avec un s à
court terme paraît plus pertinent quoi
lectoure dur avec trop où j'allais trop
électro du cycle un beau site internet
je dirais à recycler vite avec un s moi
j'ai jamais vu vite avec un ace de bois
mais peut-être que c'est vite en
sécurité sert plus à rien sert plus rien
ne sert plus à rien santé électronique
s'opérait je perds toutes les boules je
vous ai pour des quoi électrons sur elle
et toi dur c'est ça va s'cauet et perd
ses repères il sert plus à rien pour
pour jeudi
sellal j a déjà la réponse à la
politique
ils gagnent plutôt bon avec la bonne
réponse sert plus à rien mais là c'est
un peu ça sert plus adéquat ça s'est vu
plus ça sert plus alors là ça sert à
rien voilà voilà tout ça servait à
roubaix sert plus à rien vous ajustez
j'avoue que c'est un néologisme
wen au québec un crédit c'est ça alors
on apprend ça ou ne vous arrive à de ne
pas dire de ne pas mêler reprend pour je
vais pas tuer pour lui dire je n'y vais
pas personne ne comprend 1,5 d'un appui
à rien ça fait envie mais ce que je vous
raconte nouveau job contestation bien
c'est vrai pour moi c'est clair et
servent plus à rien face et d'avoir un
an française quand on grandit raccourci
moi je dessers ben j'ai appris ça sert
plus à rien on va appeler ça des
circuits et est-ce que vous pensez que
ce mot va être accepté par l'académie
française
peut-être pas mais c'est accepter au
québec par l'office l'académie divulgue
h&m aux québécois ont récemment voulu
gâcher d'y vivre caché ça veut dire quoi
si ces spoilers en anglais quand on dit
des cantons des vul que des scènes
avant qu'on voit le film québécois sous
embargo
non c'est quand on vous dit l'histoire
avant d'avoir vu le film on a préféré le
pot-aux-roses notamment avec la langue
s'enrichit de nouveaux accords ont
réhaussé grande émission qui s'appelle
image de la semaine
alors là écoutez c'est un écrasement
d'avion où je pense qu une force qu'on
n'aura pas de joue aujourd'hui ça reste
peut-être en début de semaine moi je
pensais je m'en viens vers les incendies
de forêt en australie la participation
des sapeurs pompiers canadiens qui ont
été applaudis en australie mais parce
qu'ils étaient quoi 80 autour de 80 un
peu plus certains d'entre eux reviennent
et ceux d'autres repartent et on sait
que l'australie n'est pas sorti des
femmes c'est ce qui était prévu au
programme évidemment ce qui s'est passé
mercredi moi j'étais mardi soir à la
maison et je regarde peu chauffé que sa
qualité tous devant notre télé ça n'a
pas d'alluré qu'est ce qui s'est passé
et au début moi je ne savais pas ça dit
sport au début que c'était des canadiens
à bord le lendemain matin 4 heures du
matin je regarde sur mon ordinateur soit
sans savoir qu'à rédiger sur des deux ça
c'était de là j'ai eu la chair de poule
je ne sais pas d'alluré et moi ce que
j'ai trouvé le plus difficile cette
semaine on a fait une excellente
couverture ans embellie ce sont des
couvertures en ce 8 9 articles à ce
sujet de fond et puis on a sur la page
web de tam-tam que la page web principal
du cnrc m cette fin de semaine on
appelle ça une trêve oil 752 une
tragédie canadienne notre couverture
complète tous nos articles sont là ce
qui devrait plus et c'est ce que vous
montrez ce serait dire mais c'est les
images comme toujours c'est dur puis
quand vous connaissez un peu les
histoires alors c'est dur ça devient bon
sens il ya plus d'image qu on en montre
parce qu'ils ont 75 imaginer puis
c'était des jeunes très souvent des
jeunes qui travaillent dans le domaine
de l'ingénierie la santé des gens
étaient vraiment brillant des
professeurs d'université ouais des
familles entières qui ont été décimés
des personnes très jeunes des enfants
pour des enfants dans ce vol à 276 des
gens qui profitaient du temps des fêtes
pour aller rendre visite à leur famille
dans le vol se dirigea vers kiev en
théorie est devant c'est trop bon dieu
feront de 30 voix là alors c'est ça peut
ben écoutez c'est pas un peu cette
histoire qui va continuer à être qu'on
va continuer à écouter la suite dans les
développements qui va suivre parce que
enfin il ya des inspecteurs canadien
bell avant de participer à la journée si
on ira qu'ils allaient tous vers la
solution est forte quand même passé ici
c'est un missile qui a qui est séché par
sap en tout cas ça reste un éternel de
mm mais ça va être très difficile parce
que l'iran déjà ne reconnaît pas dates
encore lui dont ils ne connaissent pas
vous n'avez pas vu le président iranien
dire je ne reconnais pas vous avez
entendu des responsables de l'agression
celui-ci refusé jusqu'ici on verra la
suite il ya de la place pour sauver la
face si la raison était sa véritablement
tout à fait ce qui est important c'est
que si on avait un message à passer à
lire à moi je ne jugez pas d'opinion là
sur ce qui s'est passé je suis pas là
mais l'important c'est de ces de montrer
patte blanche permet de faire preuve de
transparence
comme l'a dit le premier ministre hier
justin trudeau a dit vraiment ils
espèrent une enquête équitable
transparent
pour éclairer les familles sur ce qui
s'est réellement passé ce jour et le
canada compte sur l'apport de ses alliés
la france et les états unis notamment
qui font partie de la délégation qui va
donc participer à l' enquête il ya
l'ukraine faut signaler le rôle de
l'ukraine dans les pourparlers
eux qui m'ont pièce parce qu'évidemment
la majorité des citoyens qui sont morts
étaient d'origine ukrainienne lingwala
mail à l'ukraine
elle a fait des déclarations de gestes
d'entre aide auprès du canada va pas
fait pour vous la auprès des aspects le
canada n'est plus de représentations
diplomatiques en attique en iran ce qui
coûta et que dans ce cas la tâche pour
nos inspecteurs créée autour des corps
si tout est si compliqué j'ai atteint
que ils ont et plusieurs de ces
canadiens qui sont décédés avaient une
double nationalité
il y en aura donné par les troupes la
nationalité donc le citoyen qui aurait
monté à bord de l'avion avec un
passeport iranien n'est pas considéré
comme un canadien un des jeunes iraniens
alors ça pourrait compliquer encore les
choses les cas ça me rajoute à la
douleur des familles tout à fait et ça
fait une sale année une pause dans les
tensions quelque part entre entre les
etats-unis et l'iran athenes 6 et des
missiles en tout cas c'est une
catastrophe a déjà du sang inutile mais
c'est ça mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
si c'était le cas qu'est ce qui s'est
passé exactement entre un certain temps
mais bon celui-là fer rouge tout à fait
raison remis au travail pour continuer
ça et puis merci pour cette semaine ils
se marient ici merci l'invitation
toujours un plaisir vraiment par la
semaine prochaine je l'espère merci
derrien stéphane n'assistait pas à 100%
[Musique]